et vous pensez que vous soignez des
maladies ou que vous conservez la une
bonne santé avec les
[Musique]
plantesant enfant en promenade je
cueillais toujours de gros bouquets de
plantes sauvages plus tard en compagnie
de ma grand-mère je cueillis encore des
plantes sauvages et je revois ma
grand-mère me tend un brin de de serpolé
dans son corsage et quand dans le jardin
les roses anciennes étaient en fleur
elle n'hésitait pas à prendre des
pétales et de s'en mettre également dans
son corsage et je trouvais ça
formidable je cuille le serpolé au mois
de juin avant qu'il ne fleurisse et de
préférence dans une prairie loin de tout
chemin
fréquenté je suis sûre qu'il n'est pas
souillé je cuille le serpolet que je
fais en infusion et cette infusion très
agréable a de plus pour effet de guérir
les rhumes et certaines allergies je
l'emploie aussi en cuisine pour parfumer
mes civet de lièvre de lapain mes pâté
de
lapin et mes
poissons ma cuillette de sererpolé est
terminée sans attendre j'étale mes
herbes sur un papier un papier blanc de
préférence malheureusement mon grenier
étant en réflection je suis obligée de
les installer sous un
hangar la différence est que mon hangar
est plus éclairé que mon
grenier je prendrai la précaution dans
quelques jours d'étaler un autre papier
sur mes a herb pour qu'elles soit à
l'abri de la
lumière ainsi mes herbes sècheront le
temps qu'il faudra plusieurs mois sans
doute votre grand-mère se servait de
beaucoup de plantes elle se servait
principalement de bourrache de camomille
qu'elle me faisait cueillir et
quelquefois je trouvais l'ouvrage très
long et elle me faisait cuillir
également de la mauve j'ai gardé cette
habitude je je cuille toutes ces plantes
à chaque saison dans mes cueillettes je
choisis pour la menthe seulement les
feuill et pour le tyul je cueille la
feuille pour la camomille je cueille
également la feuille je cueille mes
fleurs de mauve je les cueille au mois
de
septembre alors qu'elles sont en pleine
fleur et que toutes les autres sont déjà
passées grillé par le soleil mais par
exemple pas de RAC de violette pas de
queue de cerise je je récolte également
les queue de cerises je ramasse les
risome de chien dent je cueille les
fraisiers
sauvages je cueille dans le fraisier
sauvage je cueille la racine et les
feuilles mais très souvent je récolte
les racines de piss en lit qui sont
dépuratives après avoir fait sécher mes
plantes pendant plusieurs moi euh je les
mets en pot en bocau que
j'étiquette
et en même temps j'établis des fiches
sur
lesquelles
j'inscris l'utilisation de chaque plante
ainsi pour
l'obépine dont je fais la cuueillette au
mois de mai je peux vous dire qu'elle
est recommandée pour le cœur la
circulation du sang et que je la fais en
infusion
La Bruyère que je cueille en septembre
et en octobre et que je fais en
décoction et dépurative il m'arrive de
garder des plantes pendant très
longtemps ainsi de la mauve j'en ai
depuis plusieurs années et elle est elle
est encore très bonne les que de cerises
également je ne consomme jamais toute ma
récolte et vous en donnez à vos enfants
ma fille en particulier est très
heureuse que je lui donne la manthe
mon gendre
également préfère ma manthe à celle
qu'il peut trouver dans le dans le
commerce il en est gros consommateur il
a abandonné le café après le déjeuner
pour prendre la manthe et vous pensez
que vous soignez des maladies ou que
vous conservez une bonne santé avec les
plantes je ne pense pas soigner de
maladies avec les
plantes mais je soulage j'ai
l'impression de soulager en particulier
pour les rhumes par exemple les hivers
nous consommons énormément de tisane de
serpolé avec du laurier du laurier sauce
je fais une tisane et je peux vous
affirmer qu'il y a plusieurs hivers que
nous n'avons pas eu de
rhume je pense que cela est dû au bonnes
tisanes que nous buvons les feuilles de
sa me servent à faire de la tisane que
je bois pour me soulager de mes
rhumatismes je conserve également des
coins que je coupe en lamelle que je que
je fais desséché et je l'ai fait en
décoction et je trouve qu'elles ont un
effet immédiat pour la diarrée chez les
enfants chez les
nourrissons quant aux feuilles de lis
aux pétales pardon au pétal de lis que
je conserve dans l'alcool je m'en sers
pour désinfecter les
PL je conserve également les étamines du
LCE dans de l'huile et je m'en sers
pour contre les
brûlures si bien que vous ne devez pas
souvent aller chez le pharmacien
euh j'avoue que je ne prends presque
jamais de médicament même pas un caché
d'aspirine je me contente de boire des
tisanes
et d'employer ce toutes les herbes que
je que je ramasse que je
[Musique]
cuille